hiya folks I am Walter Bernays II act
I'm Heather Roos and I'm Anna wave and
this is top 5 last week we covered the
best of visionary director Tim Burton
and this week while Tim Burton has had
an amazing career not every film he's
made has been quite so amazing like any
director he's had highs and lows since
we took a look at some of the best of
his filmography last week it's only fair
that we take a look at some of the worst
this week
these are the top 5 work these are tough
our worst neighbor brings number 5
Planet of the Apes no not that one no
not that one either
in 2029 astronaut Leo Davidson gets
caught up in an electromagnetic storm
he's then sent to a world where apes
rule and humanity is enslaved escaping
capture leo leads a group of humans and
apes to look for a holy temple called
Kalima while following a beacon to a
spacecraft from his time period I'm
gonna say right away that I don't hate
this movie I mean how could I astronomer
from Power Rangers in space as a cameo
but it does have a few things I admire
about it
the makeup for the Apes is really well
done you can see expression come through
a lot of the actors faces and Tim Roth
and Paul Giamatti especially do a
phenomenal job inhabiting these
creatures it's also not boring while
this version of Planet of the Apes isn't
near Burton's best work it at least kept
my interest the whole time one of the
main issues I have with this remake is
how unlikable and Mark Wahlberg's
character Leo is the writing doesn't
have me rooting for him as much as I
would have preferred but I know the
whole point is to show there are good
guys and bad guys on both sides
he's not exactly portrayed as the best
of humanity but I could have stood to
see more positive attributes in the
character there's also just downright
strange stuff in here that does not help
the movie
also the big twist ending just comes off
as a lame retread I won't spoil it in
case you really want to see this for the
first time but it's just kind of dumb
who knew that taking this concept 100%
seriously would yield such amazing
results the ape trilogy from recent
years have been incredible films and
blow this out of the water plus when the
director says he'd rather jump out of a
window than do a sequel it doesn't make
the 2001 version look very good I will
say that watching this for the first
time after seeing the newer trilogy at
least makes it an intriguing alternate
watch number 4 Mars Attacks maybe Tim
Burton's weirdest movie and that's
saying a lot a lot Martians have finally
made contact with earth they'll and
looking to meet with our leaders
peacefully
however it's soon obvious that peace was
never their goal and they started
vaporizing humans left and right
retaliation from Earth is delayed as US
president James Dale wants to avoid an
all-out war as the story progresses we
see that may have not been the smartest
decision first of all full spoilers for
this I don't know how anyone could get
mad at spoiling Mars Attacks but I'm
sure you're out there
this film is packed with celebrities who
play terrible people
that all die pretty quickly there are a
few characters in there that aren't
total jerks but not a ton of time is
spent on them I have to say this movie
is totally worthless it's definitely not
but I just don't know why you would make
an entire movie that should have been
the length of an SNL sketch the
recurring bits in this movie get old
fast and the more standalone jokes
either don't hold up well or just plain
unfunny Jack Nicholson plays two
characters for reasons but his main
character the president has the oddest
delivery
[Music]
also my reaction to this movie I know
Mars Attacks had tons of homage is too
old 50s era science fiction movies and
that a lot of its runtime was dedicated
to reminding you not to take it
seriously but I just got a bad vibe from
this movie I do not like it I don't ever
want to see it again but I know some
people enjoy this one so if you're one
of those people keep on keeping on man
my thoughts are best summed up by a
quote from Roger Ebert's 1996 review of
the film Ed Wood himself could have told
us what's wrong with this movie the
makers felt superior to the material to
be funny
even schlock has to believe in itself
you will find movies that lack stars and
big budgets and fancy special effects
but are funny and fun in a way that
Burton's mega production never really
understands number three dark shadows a
whole lot of yikes so let's just get
into it Barnabas Collins the wealthy
heir to the Collins family fortune and
Collinwood estate spurns the love of his
servant Angelique
unfortunately she is a witch and when
Barnabas falls in love with Josette
Angelique casts spells to kill his
parents drive Josette to suicide and
turn Barnabas into a vampire fearful of
Barnabas is new vampirism yet unaware of
Angelique powers the townspeople bury
Barnabas and forget about him for
centuries the Collins line lives on in
the dilapidated Manor when they hire a
governess for the youngest David the new
governess Victoria sympathizes with
David's plight of seeing the ghost of
his mother as she has seen ghosts as
well when Barnabas is inadvertently
unearthed he devours the helpful workers
and returns to the only home he's known
while he is welcome back to the manor
Barnabas agrees to keep his nighttime
routines under wraps
of course Angelique is still alive and
well going by Angie now and running a
successful cannery she is still in love
with him but the Collins decide to take
her on by opening their own competing
cannery after murdering a group of
hippies and declining Angie's advances
yet again the town turns against
Barnabas once more although the Collins
family stand up against the angry mob
and sorceress in the end Angie and
Barnabas must hash out their history
mano-a-mano Dark Shadows is based off
the soap opera of the same name
but doesn't go far enough with the
classic tropes and emotions it
establishes a tone in one moment and
then in the next scene drops it to
slowly build up another tone sure there
are some genuinely funny moments and
bits but as a whole it fails to do
justice to all of the characters and
plot lines it tries to follow over
centuries worth of time abandoning way
more interesting storylines like the
werewolf reveal and Alice Cooper cameo
that never get their payoffs in favor of
giving extra screen time to Johnny Depp
acting silly
while ava green smolders victoria is
established as the main protagonist as
we follow her arrival and settling into
the manor but then she's dropped in
order to follow Barnabas some more she
feels like such an afterthought Vicky
will just disappear for multiple scenes
before we see or hear about her again
which would be fine if she wasn't being
shoved down our throat as the love
interest
Barnabas is into Vicky thinking she's
reminiscent of his one true love but
also actively pursues other women
throughout its supposed to be pure and
transcend time itself but also he can
have some side action it muddies the
fact that Barnabas and Victoria only
have like five scenes together as it is
so we never see the romance develop
we're just supposed to accept it
because she resembles his dead ex
Victoria's backstory is scattered
throughout the film and instead of
feeling like we're getting in on some
dark past you get the impression that it
was forgotten during her introduction
her ability to see ghosts isn't a reveal
since she comes out and says it to David
so why do they wait until the third act
to tell us that she really did see
ghosts actually they can't decide if
Barnabas is this brooding goth with a
star-crossed lover or tall dark and
handsome mysterious stranger here to be
the answer to every woman's prayers or
this blood sucking weirdo who doesn't
get modern-day stuff because he's so
sane II for example the awkward not sex
scene in Angie's office is it supposed
to be hot or funny it was way too quick
of a mood shift from the previous
dialogue and doesn't land Depp and
Greene have weird chemistry - more like
brother and sister than lovers so that
didn't help defying gravity to go at
each other is such a unique idea but the
delivery
disappointing the movie half-asses the
fish-out-of-water stuff too will see
barnabas fumble his way not knowing
current etiquette and culture but in the
next scene used those things like he's
an expert probably because of all the
time hops between scenes I could
literally cover an entire episode worth
of problems I had with this film the
pacing is off the end is awful I didn't
even talk about most of the main
characters all that said Ava Greene
crushes it in this movie as usual and
purely got the exact vibe this movie
should have had number 2 Alice in
Wonderland it's getting harder and
harder to remember a time before these
Disney live-action remakes isn't it an
Alice in Wonderland Burton takes what
should be a charming story about
exploration of a new world and turns it
into a drab a boring action movie the
craziest part is that in theory it seems
like this should be a perfect match
Burton style is offbeat colorful
imaginative everything that people think
of when thinking about Alice in
Wonderland but everything comes out
muddled boring and uninspired even the
actors act like they're bored cause I'm
gonna fluff
I'm Sony the filmmakers tried to force a
hero's born storyline into a story that
doesn't have much narrative to begin
with it all starts with a scroll that
tells the whole history including the
future of Wonderland there we see that
alice is supposed to slay the
Jabberwocky on fresh day with the vorpal
sword the problem is that Alice doesn't
want anything to do with this the movie
can't quite decide what it wants to
focus on sometimes taking large breaks
from this plot to world build which only
complicates matters further rather than
creating anything it tries so hard to
justify the nowt dark and gritty tone
showing that Alice has been here before
as a child alluding to the animated
movie as her first visit they even go so
far as changing the name from Wonderland
to Underland so you know it's not the
same place that Alice has visions of
over-the-top and odd character choices
only add to the confusion of this edgy
snoozefest and the number one worth Tim
Burton Museum I don't care what you do
to me a can line it's Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory
when Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
first came out in 2005 reactions were
mixed we're not going to turn this
breakdown into a comparison of the Gene
Wilder version versus this movie there
are two completely different tones and
takes on the story nor are we going to
compare this movie to the book because
honestly it is a much better adaptation
of the 1971 movie I'll leave an admit
that there are some great designs and
moments but what this movie gets wrong
spoils the whole experience namely
Depp's portrayal of Willy Wonka good
morning Starshine the earth says hello
he's creepy truly odd and downright
unlikable sometimes I understand what
they were going for Wonka would be an
odd outcast but Depp veers from creating
a character to a caricature
there's nothing understated subtle or
even remotely human in the performance
the best kind of prize is a surprise
hahahaha in an attempt to humanize the
character there is a side plot about
Wonka's parents yeah it feels forced and
honestly doesn't add much to the story
nor character their bizarre relationship
and chemistry only furthered my
discomfort and dislike for the character
don't even get me started on the Oompa
Loompas another element that got too
strange
totally took me out of the movie then
again at least they're not as creepy as
these puppets burning for the
introduction of Willy Wonka it wasn't
innovative take on the story I'll give
it that but definitely missed the mark
you're really weird
Oh top fibers
[Music]
you wanted to see us Willie I tried to
warn you oh come on we couldn't help it
charlie the Chocolate Factory is just
the whoosh Walter
how long have you been hosting top 5 for
about two and a half years Heather hi
Emma
how long have you two been part of the
show a little over a year now
hmm it's over what that's right
I've canceled your show well you can't
do this
yeah hopefully you in charge anyway I'm
black Willy Wonka I can do whatever I
want
your final show is next week now get out
of here before I caramelize your insides
but good day sir
[Music]
Willie I'm sorry okay I just I said good
day when this follow me
[Music]
[Applause]
you